the chaos Queen is coming clean earlier
this week we told you about the
wonderful story of Kentucky Woman
rayanna Brock whose incredible array of
mug shots from her multiple arrests went
viral
take a look at those I think you can see
a trend here she seems like she's having
a really good time getting cuffed dare I
say she looks great very very happy I
mean she's happier getting arrested than
I am watching cat cry
talk about overcoming talk about
overcoming adversity now she used to go
by the handle the queen of chaos 23
which means there had to be 22 others
before her R.I.P
but she says with the help of family and
friends she's turned her life around and
she's ready to share her story joining
us now Rihanna Brock hey there Rihanna
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my God how you doing
I'm doing great how are you guys do it
are you just easy going and just smile
with everything or do you only smile
when you're doing a mug shot
either either or usually just the mug
shots just to make them mad
was that the strategy was that they
would you would smile because that would
upset the person taking the shot
yeah see my first mug shot I started to
smile and he was like you need to stop
smiling and I just kept smiling and he
took it anyways
now what made you um I don't even know
where to go uh
um were you maybe were you on some kind
of substance at the time
I was addicted to Xanax very badly what
are my college Years so interesting I
don't know many people addicted to Xanax
because it generally kind of like it's
much of a downer what yeah that doesn't
make sense because
you're smiling I would think you'd be on
an upper
yeah um I don't know if you've ever been
to Kentucky but most of the population
in Kentucky is addicted to Xanax
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you are amazing now
realize hmm something's not going in the
right direction or maybe you just kept
going yeah yeah
yeah you know while I'll be in jail I'd
be like okay this is my last time going
to jail I really need to clean up my act
and then I would get out like a week
later and commit another crime
you are my favorite recidivist
scared in these jails
um on
my jail visits were awesome because that
was usually the youngest girl in the
sale so they treated me like a newbie
they treated me like their kids so
everyone in there always took care of me
what got you to turn your life around
honestly
um when I was really bad on drugs I
started to look in the mirror and I just
didn't look like the same girl so really
what got me sober is how I was looking I
was looking terrible so that's really
what started my sobriety is I wanted to
look like the girl I used to
and um how long have you been sober
um since January 18 2022 that's a long
time I stopped smoking weed about five
or six months ago I was just smoking
weed after the 18th but I had to quit
that for probation so you're the best
you know um smoke like it's hard to get
arrested when you're on pot right
because you don't break any laws but
it's just interesting that Xanax is what
not made you go crazy I bet that's an
underreported story that Kentucky is
filled with people on Xanax
um why did you choose to public get all
your dude were you collecting these uh
mug shots
um no I really wasn't collecting them I
mean I do have an album on my phone of
all of them now but
everyone really sent in my mugshots I
don't even know really who did
um but they sent them to mug shawties
and that's how I got my newfound Fame so
mugs shoddies that's I guess that's a
combination of mug shots and Hotties are
you uh now were you did you feel did you
feel happy that you were a mugshoddy a
hot mug shot yeah yeah I was looking
through all of the girls and it did make
me kind of happy I was like you know I
feel blessed to be on here I was honored
yes I mean you are definitely one of a
kind you um I I got to ask you about
your handle chaos Queen so you kind of
already knew you were trouble when did
you decide to call yourself chaos Queen
I honestly seen somebody comment on one
of my mug shots and they was like this
is the queen of chaos she's a menace to
society and I just love that so
credit to them all right I gotta go but
I got what are you working now are you
uh in school what are you doing now
yes we actually
um me and my boyfriend own our own
business it's called Ragnar remodels
it's a general contracting business
um but I'm a server bartender been a
server bartender since I was like 16. I
love it honestly yeah what part can they
if they want to if they want to meet you
as at the bartender you get a picture
let's close that information but
stalkers right now for my most I don't
know if that's a safe thing for me to do
very smart
very smart thank you Rihanna Brock
you're the queen of chaos don't go away
we'll be right back hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else